[Music]
this episode is sponsored by myheritage
which helps you discover your family
history and origins
to check out myheritage click the link
in the description for a 14 day free
trial and if you decide to continue your
subscription you'll get a 50 percent
discount
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign activity that mostly involves
sitting and staring microscopy is a
surprisingly high stakes task
on the other side of the lens are drops
full of potential a multitude of worlds
to unravel and examine
but they're also fragile worlds easy to
fracture and lose with just a tiny slip
of the hand
the stakes only get higher when you're
dealing with an organism like this
dactyl-aclaimus pisiformis
a creature so rare that it's only been
reported a few times since it was first
discovered in 1901
this was one of those rare sightings a
clip we showed in a previous episode
because we were so excited to find
something so unlikely
watching it swim around on its own
oblivious to our presence it seems like
this is what spotting a solitary tiger
in the wild would feel like distant
unique
and all the more precious for its rarity
but one day our singular microbial
friend
vanished without a trace
leaving a trail of mysteries and
inspiration in its wake
finding this one dactyloclamus pushed
james our master of microscopes to try
and find more
so he went back to the spot where he'd
found it
sampling the same waters over and over
again so that he had drops and drops to
sift and sort through for hundreds of
hours on end
but for months
nothing turned up
until finally
one did
the sight had james's hands shaking with
excitement
it's one thing to put all that work into
finding a rare organism but the reality
of success that's something else
altogether
and all of those feelings the thrill of
discovery the satisfaction of work
paying off they were in this case
also interlaced with the fragility of
what james had found
on the one hand he wanted to be able to
watch it live its life and record those
moments
capture them so that its morphology and
behavior could be etched into a vivid
record for scientists to study and draw
conclusions from
but video is risky to be able to see so
deeply into the organism james has to
watch it with the objective close to the
sample which leaves room for only a thin
layer of water for the dactyl acclaimes
to survive in and sometimes they don't
survive which means we would lose both
the organism and the possibility of
learning more about it
we'd already lost one dactyloclamus
we didn't want to lose another
so
james was very very careful
transferring the ciliate from the larger
sample to a slide and then gently
covering it with the cover slit he added
a drop of immersion oil to the coverslip
and dipped his best microscope objective
into the oil and then he pressed record
gathering around 25 minutes in the life
of a rare microbe
[Music]
in 1901
robert louderbourne the german biologist
who discovered dactyl acclaim as
pisiformis
gave what is perhaps the best
description of the organism
saying
it is one of the most bizarre and
striking microbes i know
and he's right this might be a strange
reference to make for an organism we
were excited to find but there's
something about this dactyloclamus that
resembles a lopsided eye of sauron it's
that combination of the elongated shape
the large round contractile vacuole on
the posterior side of its body and the
clutter of structures that project out
like the spikes of a fire
maybe a better comparison is this
actinobellina
another cilia that we've talked about on
this channel
for the actinobelina those tentacle-like
spikes have a clear purpose
they help the organism trap food and
feed so perhaps the dactyloclamus uses
its own spikes for a similar purpose
but until we see them in action we won't
know for sure but james also noticed
something when he was comparing this
second dactyl claimus to the first one
he found
they didn't quite look the same
there were subtle differences in their
macronucleus and cilia and other parts
that made him think that maybe they're
different organisms
that maybe the organism he found last
year was actually not a dactyl acclaim
is pisiformis but actually a related
species called dactyloclamus hysteres
that was discovered in 1928 and then
never found again
until james
because both of these species have been
so difficult to find their descriptions
are sparse and incomplete so for now we
believe that the first one that james
found was dactyl acclaim as high stress
and the second one was a dactyl acclaim
as pisiformis and james is working on
uncovering as much as he can with the
tools we have today
[Music]
when both dactyloclamus pisiformis and
dactyl acclaim as hysteres were
discovered the ability to study them at
the genetic level wasn't available yet
but this is a different era and james
was careful with his dactyl claim as
pisiformis in part so he could study its
dna
but the stakes were still high
and so he still needed to be careful he
took the slide with the cover slip on
top and floated it in water
letting him carefully remove the cover
slip without killing the precious
organism inside
then he needed to clean the
dactyloclamus to make sure there was
nothing else that might contaminate his
sample and affect his results
so he used a pipette to grab the
organism and move it over to a clean
drop of water
and then again to another drop
and then one more
to one last drop before storing it in a
tiny tube in his freezer
from there this frozen dactyloclamus
will have part of its dna sequenced
revealing the genes that make it the way
it is and maybe even uncovering some of
its closest microbial relations
and that's only the beginning the first
two dactyloclamuses that james found
took a tremendous amount of time and
patience
but in the last four months he's found
more than 20 of them 20.
that's not a huge number by microbe
discovery standards where the rapid
reproduction means that you can
sometimes stumble on colonies of
hundreds of a single organism
but for any dactyl acclaimed species
20 is a windfall
some of them have been frozen for their
own dna studies while others have been
put under the microscope for james to
watch
and sometimes he sees something new like
this species that might be dactyl
acclaimed as heist dress and that seems
to be extending its tail out
other times the things he finds are very
new like new species new
when you zoom in you can see how similar
yet distinct it is from the other
species we've seen but it'll still be
some time before we know enough to know
whether it really is a new species
in the meantime though the fact that we
found more of these dactyloclamuses
means that we have more chances to learn
more about them
because sure finding a rare organism is
thrilling
but even more thrilling is the chance to
make it a little less rare
the stakes of finding one may be lower
but that doesn't lessen the joy of
discovery
of having made something feel more
common
and realizing it's still precious
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us
and thank you again to myheritage for
sponsoring this episode
if the prospect of building a family
tree has felt intimidating to you in the
past
my heritage makes it easier
using myheritage you can search for and
find historical records of your family
and ancestors easily and you might even
discover new relatives in the process
the site not only gives you powerful
tools to reconnect with your family
history they also have advanced ai
technologies that you can use to restore
colorize and enhance old family photos
their deep nostalgia tool even lets you
create a short animation of the faces in
your photos
myheritage is the number one family
history service in europe and has over
16 billion records for you to explore
and right now you can sign up for a 14
day free trial and enjoy all the
features myheritage has to offer at the
link in the description
and if you decide to continue your
subscription you'll get a 50 discount
we'd also like to thank each and every
person whose name is on the screen right
now these are some of our patreon
patrons and without them and all of our
other patrons whose names aren't on the
screen right now
this channel could not exist
so thank you again to all of them and
all of you for watching and supporting
this channel
if you'd like to join our patreon
community you can do so over at
patreon.com
journey2micro
if you'd like to see more from our
master of microscopes james weiss you
can check out jam and germs on instagram
and if you'd like to see more from us
there's probably a subscribe button
somewhere nearby
[Music]